over here Julia Pierpont Xinhua news of
China congratulations
it's unbelievable this is actually
really exciting in China as well you've
obviously been sweeping the globe but
now it's really hitting China I'm really
curious what you think is what creates
that extraordinary general appeal the
short answer is that I don't know and I
wish I did because if I did that would
mean we could we could do it again but
the longer slightly longer answer is
that Westeros doesn't belong to anybody
nobody has a history of family in
Westeros nobody is personally connected
to it and that means that everybody can
be equally connected to it and I think
that that's it touches on George's
genius was such that he he took all of
world history and condensed it into his
world and I think everybody it's a
mirror in which everybody can see
themselves and their people in their
history questions anybody else right
over here straight ahead to the right of
the pole hi everyone David from Israel
Mazel Tov to all of you it seems like
you know we've been being on a festival
of you know the sister the season before
last the last season it split into you
know to hat in like seven episodes and
six episodes it's like an ongoing you
know delaying the ending do you feel
that as well
on your end no you know to be honest the
the final seasons taking along tour
taking a long time because it's the
biggest thing we've ever done and even
though it's six episodes
it took us how many more shooting days
the normal burning would you say I mean
it was it yeah so it was nearly a full
year in Belfast either prepping it or
actually shooting it and it's I think
it's quite extraordinary what the crew
and these actors have created and I
think when people see it they understand
they're gonna understand why it took so
long so it's really not it's no one's
going on vacation no one's slacking off
it's just that last season is far beyond
what we've ever attempted before
and it's taken a really [ __ ] long
time but uh I hope it'll be worth it
anybody else right here on the
right-hand side hi there Angela Bishop
from Network Ten Australia George I was
wondering if I could ask you a question
please do you feel that this creation of
yours has changed television and do you
have plans to change it some more
[Laughter]
well I think television has always been
changing but it's what's exciting to me
I've spent my life in the worlds of
science fiction and fantasy and until
Game of Thrones all those science
fiction fantasy shows had occasionally
been nominated for the Emmy they'd never
actually won it and the the amount of
recognition we've gotten I think I don't
know if this changed television but it's
changed science fiction and fantasy
television and we've achieved a level of
respectability thanks to the genius of
these actors and producers and writers
that has made us equal to any genre as
for what's going to happen from now well
you know they've they're wrapping up the
show but we do have five prequels in
various stages of development so we're
not done with Westeros yet and there are
many more stories to tell one more
question on the look-back left thank you
very much this question is for both
Amelia and for kid if you could both
step to the mic please since you avoided
us on the carpet
and I'm sorry I'm not from Australia
Israel or China I'm just from Los
Angeles so bear with me here quick
question how has life changed for both
of you because of this project I mean
what really has happened in your lives
because of this well I mean in step to
the mic please yeah okay sorry I met my
wife in this show so in that way it gave
me my hopefully my future family and and
my life from here on in that's the main
thing it did for me and then it's given
you know it's changed it completely the
last 10 years you could not ask for a
better job to have in your twenties to
take you through your twenties than to
be an actor in Game of Thrones it it's
been the most amazing thing so it's
changed it completely obviously thank
you kid Amelia yeah really similar part
from the wife bit basically yeah it's
it's given me my entire career and a
it's given me my entire life as I know
it now so it's kind of I genuinely I
absolutely everything and it's changed
everything so I'm incredibly lucky
congratulations Thank You
congratulations thank you very much
you